ce que vous allez nous donner un petit
scoop est ce qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas été retenus après les castings parce
que vous avez fait passer des castings
mais ce cas des stars qui n'ont pas été
retenues y est sûr y en a plein yakhi
sinon ils allaient alors atone et
franchement au moins trois selles croit
nantua ain sel et je renonçais vous 3 3
1 déjà à hockey par exemple christian
des 12 coups de midi le grand gagnant de
départ j'aurais christian des 12 coups
de midi n'a pas été pris
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai un autre nom du jeune suicide à
la fin
qui a été recalé de danse avec les stars
allez un deuxième nom on en aura 1
toutes les dix minutes
c'est une fille cette fois ci c'est une
fille cette fois ci sachant le annie
cordy
parce que quand nous voir ceux qui ont
été pris soin d'y surtout pas été pris
maman wali je trouve ça très très
dommage d'ailleurs qu'elle ne soit pas
retenu pour cette émission et c'est une
excuse france non une ex miss france
geneviève de fontenay miss france qui
n'a pas été payé sophie thalmann sophie
thalmann la famille
camilla michel qu'à nice hier n'a pas
guéri
mesbah ce sur quoi on fait pour repérer
quelqu'un baille je passe sur les gars
alors ce n'est pas qu'une question de
danse parce que moi je fais passer quand
même des casses j'ai fait passer
quelques saisons une blague et et donc
non le sait pas que niveau danse c'est
d'accord comment il se présente comment
ils sont d'accord
baba très bien on a eu un autre nom est
ce qu'ils ont quelque chose à vendre
csssae galore dieu vous dire donc on a
eu vous voyez un les chéris on a eu deux
personnes voilà donc christian des 12
coups de midi et camille cher on en aura
une autre dans dix minutes une personne
qui a été évincée du casting de danse a
quitté sanaa je sais je sais ça vous
fout la dure et c'est comme ça quand on
doit dire les choses on l'émirat pour
l'instant on a eu du gros scoop si vous
nous rejoignez un à un sur des 12 coups
de midi
on l'a eu qu'à me sers miss france une
des miss france
hélas une troisième personne va tomber
cette personne il n'a pas été retenu
pour cette enseigne et cela
qui la donne c'est maxime où c'est
sylvia et sylviane ou là nous donnera la
dernière à 21h précises et ça va chier
des bulles carey attendait 500 stocks
alors vous en donne rayssac à 21h qui
s'est fait recaler de danse avec les
stars
marco du bachelor quoi emmerdes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non sans déconner maintenance et c'était
vrai donilon un autre parce que la salle
hélène je m'appelle hélène dans les
soutes une fille a toujours au lieu
d'appeler on lui avait envoyé des sms
est d'accord oui elle a jamais eu de
retour de textos et web et moi aussi mon
envoyé pour danse avec les stars
vous n'êtes pas d'accord j'ai dit oui
d'accord mais on verra sa télé ça c'est
ça ton problème c'est que tu as trop
vite comme l'a dit on a pour l'instant
christian des bouches cousues on à macau
du match alors on est on un élève au
lycée s'est repris dans terre et
quelques amis chers alors autre nom mais
des tirs au but d'y aller la boue non
non non non c'était plus apparemment pas
faire conseiller vous en effet donné
alors allez-y
il ya eu moundir qui était organisée à
huawei est aussi la main non non lui
aussi
lio nom est en fait ils ont pris que des
faits le meilleur casting c'est celui
qu'ils ont pas pris on va sentir
eh bien merci bravo les besoins